la unión europea suman potenciales
trabas a la exportación de vacunas el
bloque decidió que la entrega de
fármacos a terceros países se tendrá en
cuenta si esas naciones también exportan
vacunas a la unión europea y el nivel de
avance de sus campañas de inmunización
estos dos criterios se suman a veces ya
existente que disponía un freno a las
exportaciones si éstas impedían a las
farmacéuticas cumplir los compromisos
adquiridos con la unión europea las
autoridades afirmaron que la medida
busca garantizar la vacunación de su
población en medio de una situación
epidemiológica agravada la revisión del
mecanismo de transparencia de las
exportaciones llegan un momento en que
la situación sigue siendo alarmante en
muchos estados miembros estamos
empezando a ver circunstancias cada vez
más preocupantes constantes ser
constantes aunque lo que pretende
analizar caso por caso y negó que la
medida apunte de algún país en
particular el mecanismo busca garantizar
la reciprocidad y proporcionalidad en el
intercambio de vacunas en particular con
reino unido y el fabricante astrazéneca
jost
introducción desde la introducción del
sistema de autorización de exportaciones
unos 10 millones de dosis han sido
exportadas de la unión europea reino
unido y ninguna de reino unido a la
unión europea 02 es jardín exporters
convocase tú y yo las tensiones entre
londres y bruselas se han disparado a
partir de la entrega irregular de
vacunas de 8 vóley astrazéneca
reino unido ha advertido a la unión
europea que evite el nacionalismo de las
vacunas y no veten las exportaciones de
los fármacos